uzman khan a 28 year old man from
staffordshire
is the suspect behind yesterday's london
bridge knife attack
he was an islamic terrorist convicted in
2012 and released
on license in 2018 khan was known to the
security services
and believed to be wearing an electronic
tag he was wrestled to the ground by
members of the public
and then shot by specialist firearm
officers
a suicide vest he was wearing is
believed to be a fake
police say two people a man and a woman
were killed in the attack
three people a man and two women were
injured
two of them seriously the prime minister
said the incident showed the need for
tougher sentencing
it is a mistake to allow
serious and violent criminals to come
out of
prison early and it is very important
that we get out of that habit and that
we enforce
the appropriate sentences for dangerous
criminals
especially for terrorists
last night the government faced tough
questions about how a known terrorist
was able to carry out such a brutal
attack
i have just come from cobra and the
meeting chaired by the prime minister
and of course there's various strands of
information that's coming together
but this is a police investigation and
so it's inappropriate for me to
comment on reporting or even elements of
reporting that are speculative
police say the attack began as khan was
attending an event
at fishmongers hall on the north side of
london bridge
cordons remain in place but police say
they're not looking for anyone else in
connection with these tragic events
noel phillips sky news